[Musique]
comair fois cette semaine que le député
gerry sklavounos revient à l'assemblée
nationale après son départ dans la
controverse le 20 octobre en raison
d'allégations de nature sexuelle des
regards seront certainement tourné vers
lui au salon bleu pendant la période des
questions
mais il sera dans un coin discret il a
perdu son siège du côté du gouvernement
où il était leader parlementaire adjoint
son nouveau siège à titre d'indépendant
de l'autre côté complètement sous la
tribune la presse jusqu'à vous 900 ainsi
perdu de nombreux privilèges baisses de
salaires et de son budget de
fonctionnement du temps de parole et
sans parler du poids politique de ne
plus être au gouvernement
à sa droite c'est le siège de pierre
paradis aussi exclu du parti libéral
pour des allégations de nature sexuelle
et puisqu'il est en congé une maladie
sclavunos pourra causer avec claude
surprenant récemment exclu de la carte
pour des cons discutable devant lui des
députés de la cac et non loin mano masse
et amir khadir de québec solidaire qui
ont dénoncé de façon virulente kaboul as
pour ses gestes présumés non c'est
school de vieux menant cochon qui se
trouve drôle ce gaillard
on peut probablement parier que les
députés observons aussi les charges de
regards entre manon massé et jusqu'à
menace
[Musique]